alors princesse hermine je fais comme
stéphane bern le prince termine
bonsoir vous appartenait à l'une des
vies famille ducale de france buccale
autant pour moi le premier clairement
tonnerre sa revente à 1100 après
jésus-christ oui et vous vous passez
votre vie avec magloire basile de coqs
emmanuel de brantes ya pas une espèce de
déchéance non non total total bien alors
vous dirige une société de relations
publiques
hermine vous organiser des soirées où on
offre des portables non pas du tout mais
s'est plutôt dégradée de l'art des
déchets des uns alors que j'ai publié
chez michel lafon
en 2001 un livre qui s'appelait un jour
mon prince viendra et aujourd'hui chez
le même éditeur vous publier mon prince
est venu vous préparer mon prince barret
c'est parti pour les hommes alors c'est
en tout cas laurent stone une espèce de
guide annuel déchets bien sûr non plus
pour rencontrer le prince charmant mais
pour garder son mât car là je sais c'est
le pragmatisme à la ville par l'unss et
c'est je pense que je trouve et je fais
tout ce que je peux pour le garder un an
je pense que je trouve quand même pas
rien quand même
1 il est pas joli joli tu sais quoi
à redon
on pense un peu mais revel on repense un
peu haut mais nadine de rothschild genre
je fais tout ce que je peux pour garder
mon mec un peu donc amenés à côté comme
ça fait donc un ça va c'est pas non plus
attirer plus qua non premier livre vous
allez expliquer vous attendiez le prince
charmant caracolant sur son cheval blanc
et finalement vous rabattez sur un mec
que vous connaissez vaguement où l'avait
déjà vu nous avait jamais fait attention
à lui
mais non je me rends pas va sur un mec
que je croise depuis des années il faut
lire jusqu'au bout
il joue du baladeur zune on dit comme ça
c'est qu'il a lu je suis un bouquet de
fleurs et des poèmes et suis tombé sous
le charme a trouvé génial je fais couler
pourquoi pourquoi tu tu croises
quelqu'un va je sais pas moi où tu as
rencontré ta femme
mais est-ce que la première fois que tu
l'as vu tu dis c'est la femme de me lie
aux privilèges
un jour j'arrive à l'est là les assises
du dit on va se marier bien sur le coup
de foudre c'est sacré bonhomme et sa
région avaient d'accord moi je veux
t'assurer galissaire c'est un magnifique
le foudre et là je souhaite qu'une chose
du genre mais tu peux connaître
quelqu'un et apprendre à découvrir après
il n'y a pas qu'une annonce à marie tu
peux pas dire ça c'est la magie du
direct elle l'a dit mais peut pas
répondre à chaque fois pour tout le
monde que je connais dans le bar en tout
cas l'on saura rien
écoute moi voilà laurent je vais prendre
le rang comme comme juge arbitre
il est bon a raison et il est de taille
moyenne
un peu épais les messieurs qu'on voit la
science qui veut absolument
il est brun de taille moyenne un peu
épais ibos dans la finance
il est 18 heures par jour au bureau
voilà non mais je veux dire c'est pas
non plus vraiment très bien mais ils
sont les meilleurs au sais pas je ne
suis pas sympa parce qu'en plus le
bouquin ne parle que d'amour de passion
et de fonds n'a pas la même lecture du
livre la cepal et pas deux ou trois
relevés de compte
non mais c'est pas grave en même temps
c'est normal vous êtes pragmatique comme
à n'ont pas dit ou maps éléments de ce
sentiment que j'ai en lisant le livre
mais tu l'as mallié mais non alors voici
pour garder ce qu'on a c'est un peu la
méthode coué quand même hein c'est un
peu c'est vrai qu'il est formidable
c'est vrai qu'il est formidable vous
persuader on voit bien en lisant un
bouquin vous persuader qu'il est
formidable média ce qu'il ya de plus que
les autres il est super drôle et
original il m'amuse
tout le temps des surprises on peut
jouer à cache-cache comme valeur de 4
ans mais non mais c'est mitterand qui
sommeille en toi est décédé tirer c'est
un breton veut ouvrir les toits l'accord
messapresse la couette et un truc est
terrible dans votre bouquin c'est les
efforts ça c'était un étudiant un coup
un couple c'est du boulot mais
évidemment on attend des millions
habitent c'est pas nous c'est magique
c'est magique un couple c'est à dire
quand tu vois les gars de les quantités
de divorce à paris thème 2 coupes sur
trois qui sont divorcés c'est pas si
facile que ça et en plus ce divorce au
bout de quatre ans entre trois et quatre
ans non mais quand on est un couple
c'est du boulot ça veut dire qu'on se
donne du mal on ya cinq ans j'ai du
boulot et a toujours une manière de voir
les choses où tu l'as vue du maire
positive et venger de nature je suis
super positif et quand tu aimes la
personne c'est pas du boulot tu vont
être supprimés ou d'écouter votre
costume on d'une collection une société
du tout ce que tu veux tu le fais avec
amour et patiente à collection c'est du
boulot et pourtant c'est tout ce que tu
aimes cette impatience est dessinée
s'est créé des tissus c'est tout ça mais
tu peux pas dire que c'est que dirait
que du bien il ya du travail derrière ni
plein de choses alors gloser en amour
qui a fait des tas de films sur l'amour
est ce qu'un couple c'est du boulot mais
c'est pas que ça ferait plaisir en tous
les cas on est bien mais surtout rida
c'est le seul c'est la seule
c'est seulement lundi entre l'école ya
aucune école donc sonné au jugement de
la mort faisant l'amour oui mais quand
vous faites vos fils
vous allez
devant les gens et de gerbe et là tu
vois le mal qui s'est donné tout ça
donne la nausée de tourner
ainsi que toi
j'ai beaucoup joué
c'est un mot
les plateaux safin c'est moi qui vais
toucher les droits je louche film pour
moi ça ne rame pas ses produits des
questions et film presque un couple
c'est du boulot claude pas les premiers
jours après quand on fait les cantons
fait les heures sup oui quand on a
l'occasion oui mais voilà tu vois et lui
c'est un spécialiste l'on est ce que un
couple c'est du boulot oui il vaut mieux
avoir du boulot vous êtes sans emploi
moi j'étais rires je trouve qu'il ya le
côté alors d'abord la méthode coué c'est
là mon mec qui est formidable mais
qu'est formida s'ils ont su convaincre
100 mag est formidable ensuite un couple
issu du boulot un couple ça se construit
c'est un peu laborieux et alors après
tout le côté nadine de rothschild
c'est-à-dire faut faire tourner la
maison tout en restant sexy enfin il
faut s'occuper des animaux il faut faire
des concessions à savoir la fermer
écoute moi je vais dire la bt je suis
pas féministe mais je suis choqué par
pour les frangins ben oui parce que
c'est un livre d'un seul coup qui on se
croit dans les années 60 quoi d'un seul
coup c'est le sait le retour aux femmes
des années 60 quelque assez pas la
parité la lutte pour la parité mesurant
galant et qui nous gâte c'est par
exemple il faut accepter d'être trompés
quant à trouver la facture du portable
qui lui a offert la facture détaillée là
où il envoyait 30 sms par jour et une
gonzesse tu passe l'épongé aussi non
mais t'as le droit ce que j'ai en train
de tester l'impression d'être vues 72
heures il ya quatre ans de vie commune
et voilà on sait jamais heureusement car
demain non à ben si tu acceptes le taux
de l'état du tout dans les 30 sms par
jour tu dis rien tu nous lis pas
jusqu'au bout je suis parti oui tu es
parti buteur venu quoi mais faut aussi
tu sais pas avoir la vie de côté un peu
jolie voix alors que tu vis plus tu
t'inquiètes tu n'entends si vous tous
les secrets dont mehdi le terme il faut
tout accepter
non je dis qu'il faut tout accepter au
contraire s'est dit attention aux coups
de canif dans le contrat
petit coup de tenues dans le contrat
parce qu'il n'ya pas avec mon bon alors
il ronfle iront brace arrivait déjà bien
il ronge pas mais il est contesté trop
fort il continue à voir ses potes et les
jeunes amis de ses potes et toi tu dis
rien texte de moi ça s'arrange j'irai
faire la fête avec des potes et tout
médicament mais t'es sûr n'en mettais
sur vraiment que c'est le bon ton
sérieux parce que c'est sûr que c'est
l'huile ou t'es même pas épouser hermine
il est déjà marié à 12 enfants
bennoo mais pourquoi on devrait rentrer
dans un système qui te fait plaisir à
toi tu fais que sidiki balade ton truc
je suis désolé mon système ne rentrent
pas dans dans ta catégorie dans ta bulle
peut vivre à londres avec lui béatrice
cuzin et donc c'est quand même plus
drôle que paris quatre fois plus funky
et drouot plus anglais c'est sûr c'est
pas le prendre sûrement elle espère
lancer mais la france c'est
un doute maintenant
à
en
oui
mais pourquoi il est flouté le chef
patrick hernandez
oui assez sa housse zucchero qui se
laisse aller c'est ça non patrick
hernandez born to be alive et tulle m a
passionné balle hors jeu l'essentiel et
c'est pour la vie ou pas tu as lu son
livre